hello everyone and welcome to the moment
you've all been waiting for uh
chapter two of the age of kaiser is now
live and is uh
uh ready for your viewing pleasure uh
now
uh we haven't uh been we haven't
released a chapter for quite some time
now uh the first chapter we released was
last year in october and then we had a
bit of a pause
uh mostly due to my uh surgery i had a
heart surgery in october and it took us
a while to get back on track but now
chapter 2 is here and it's very very
enjoyable
now i've made a video on chapter one if
you remember uh last year uh it will be
the first thing you see in the
description below so if you still
haven't seen it
do check it out where we discuss uh
everything about the project how the
project came to be who's involved in the
project and the what
are some of our hopes and dreams
regarding this project
and uh now that chapter two has been
released you will see that
it uh improved greatly we've taken into
consideration a lot of your
uh suggestions uh from from that video
on on chapter one
and just to give you an example uh this
is basically the website where the manga
is located it is the
agarmator.com website and here okay if
you load it
there's even a nice animation here uh
abby put it there for for some reason
he's uh he's a funny guy
uh but uh yeah here you go under manga
and there's the age of kai so you have
the chapter one the chapter two the
world of kaiser
tales from kaiser meet the kaisens um
there you will see
uh all the character characters that you
can meet
uh then not all of them for now there
will be more of them and here
uh you can read zed's diary zed is our
protagonist here uh
protagonist in the uh in the manga and
well uh this will all be uh filled over
time
uh but uh a little bit uh and pieces are
released
every now and then so here if you
remember uh okay let's uh
in case you guys are new here so okay
let me just um
improve this for some reason that
there's still the uh interface from from
the game
uh but this is basically the age of
kaisa here you have the introduction you
have the chapter one chapter two chapter
three
you can download the pdfs uh you can
check
out uh who is involved in in the
creation of the of the age of kaiser
uh for example uh you can read about the
creative team and here
uh these are all the people that are
involved tinchuk who is
as uh obvious as he's the man the myth
the legend he's our very own artist and
illustrator
then you have dr genesis also uh you
know him by
uh the name of adam ledford uh he's been
uh well uh he
has been on the channel uh quite a lot
and you've even
seen his streams uh he not only streams
incredible stuff
aside of chess but also sometimes plays
chess and uh
he even played a bullet match against me
once and he did incredibly well
but yeah like it says here when not
working on his various meta-dimensional
pursuits dr genesis draws rights makes
music and sells trinkets
so here you can read uh more about the
theme dr x
writing concept and design along with
the superb art team uh we have
watersloktitocholak
who designed the the chapter one cover
uh the colorful spunky and the great
foil to the manga know our style
then you have lava art who is uh the
artist behind
the second chapter cover uh lava art is
a mangaka in his own right check out his
work here there you will be able to
click on it with
his wild imagination and clean lines we
are glad to involve him in the kaiser
project stay tuned for more lab art
involvement
uh in the future and myself uh who you
uh who you have uh well pretty much
known uh since i
run this channel uh but that's the theme
and as you can see the team
is slowly but surely expanding so we are
uh
always interested in acquiring more
people
uh regarding anything if you if you're
interested in art if you're interested
in
you know maybe contributing to the story
maybe yeah in any way
just you know uh drop us a line and
we'll see if we can get you involved uh
so uh
that's regarding the the age of kaiser
so here you can read chapter one chapter
two
uh there's the tales from kaiser also a
very important part
where you will be able to read short
stories as it says here
uh dozens of illustrated stories from
the kaiser verse spinning uh
spanning hearts sci-fi adventure comedy
horror alternate histories
and more serially released over the
coming months they are all either
uh part of the main storyline prequel
sequel extended universe or generally
about
chess and sci-fi so here if you want to
dive into it uh
some are longer some are shorter but
they are all all equally
impressive i would suggest you uh maybe
try with
znt in the automaton
uh because it's uh very short and it's
uh really really interesting
uh all of these uh when you read them uh
i can even show it to you when you read
them there are illustrations so you can
and not only you don't just read but you
also kind of get
the the sense of the world uh where
where they live and you know
what's what's everything uh uh what
everything looks like
but basically what i'm trying to tell
you here that
we've uh read your comments on chapter
one there were many of them
many of them were incredibly uh uh
detailed and uh well uh you you guys
really uh
wanted us to improve in a lot of ways
and we definitely tried
so here uh this is an example of chapter
one
uh for those of you who've seen it okay
this is the cover by water slav
really really uh awesome one uh
definitely one one for the ages
uh and here you can see that the style
of chapter one as
it's portrayed here uh i'm not gonna
spoil it to you in case you you you
haven't read it
uh but just uh to give you a taste uh it
definitely is different from chapter two
so this is chapter two
uh there there's the cover art by lava
art
so you can enjoy that as well uh it's
all free it's all
downloadable so you can you know use it
for your uh you know backgrounds on on
pc laptop
smartphone uh and here this is the art
for
for chapter two so you can you can see
it uh greatly differs from
uh chapter one and uh well
uh i i think we definitely uh improved
and the the the the process of creating
the manga has
drastically uh increased in speed
uh so you know i don't want to show you
too much but uh
just wanted to let you guys know that
you can enjoy it here so here
you have the world of kaiser uh
regarding uh everything that that's
happening here currently there isn't uh
all that much here
uh but there will be uh so here you can
uh meet
the kaisens so who is uh who is in this
story
uh the grandfather you have said uh you
have the little
uh bought fritz uh the the the century
is the machine guardian
uh who is mother so everything uh about
uh
everything and everyone uh can be found
here and also
uh there's the zed diary where you will
uh there are constantly
uh uh little bits of pieces being added
so here you have zid's diary ones as
diary twos as diary three
and it's basically uh a little bit of
the universe uh that uh
zed uh you know writes down and uh you
it's good to know
what what she thinks because you don't
actually see that in the manga
but uh you know after after some time it
will all uh
nicely nicely come together and it's uh
definitely interesting to
hear her own thoughts uh in the manga
because so far there are only two
chapters
and okay you definitely have a general
idea
about zed and what she's like but
reading the diary definitely
uh definitely uh you know that makes it
easier and gives you a broader picture
of
uh uh what's actually happening in her
mind
uh so yeah that's uh pretty much uh
that's pretty much it
uh we are we're basically funding this
all by ourselves so most of you
uh some of you have contributed but all
of the contributions are
more than welcome you you for
contributions to
towards the manga uh you can use the
link in the description below
uh and also i would just like to thank
everyone who
who donated uh for for the first chapter
uh that's not the one sorry those are
the donations for the
for the tournament uh let me just
quickly
uh improve that okay just give me a
second here
i even made a nice a nice graphic of it
yeah all right there we go
okay so these are the the contributors
of the
uh of the chapter one uh so let me just
get the ah there we go nice
so these are the contributors of chapter
one
uh let me just put this right here
okay there we go and there's a little
bit of the map
of the kaiser that is not the scale here
you can see the wastelands the human
town
the dead forest the sunken sea the
machine labs the academy the beach
uh mother's lair and a lot of other very
interesting stuff
the the the map is also available on the
website so you can check that out as
well
uh so far it's not the scale as it says
here and uh
well it's definitely one that will be
improved over time but
this is just uh you know uh this is uh
legendary to have it to have it like
this
in its absolute beginnings as we we we
really do have
big plans for this world so thank you
very much for for our contributions all
of the contributors have been added to
chapter one and
chapter two on the last page and uh we
hope uh
uh that that uh over time we will be
able to
uh do more you know uh get get more
people into the project and
expand but uh for now i think we've
we've done a pretty
pretty good job at uh uh at the
character creation at the world creation
and
you know just just getting everything
started because even though it might
seem like it's very simple it's uh it's
it's kind of really not uh but you know
we're getting there so chapter three is
already on the way and it should
arrive much much faster than chapter two
we had a like uh
seven months seven months break after
chapter one uh but now
uh as it says on on the web uh website
uh should be
you know getting along uh much much
faster maybe even every two two months
but
will see how it goes uh so yeah here uh
okay uh
when when you go to home uh there's the
actual map of the kaisa so
you can uh enlarge this if you wanna see
it in its
you know in its full glory uh so there
you have it
also you can download it you know check
it out everything that's there
everything and anything on this website
uh and in the manga
contains uh you know something hidden
and it's very well thought out by our
mastermind of the of the world behind
that uh the
abi the magician uh so you know uh when
you read the manga
don't just think everything is you know
there for for no reason
uh trust me everything is there for for
a reason
uh so okay i don't want to make this
video too long basically i just wanted
to
tell you that it's uh here uh chapter
two is out uh
do check it out and let us know in the
comments uh if we were if we were
successful in improving from chapter one
uh because okay there were some comments
like
yeah you should do this you should do
this you should do this you should hire
a better team you should i mean
uh we're not trying to like do that
we're trying to
we have a team that we really like we
really like each other and we're
you know uh really enjoying creating
this from scratch
and we're trying to you know create this
into something that can expand
further into who knows maybe even like
maybe even like
anime or maybe video games or will see
where it takes us but we want to do it
together so that's our uh that's our uh
plan
for for the moment uh but i i don't
think we we
any of us would you know want to do it
any any other way
so those kind of comments uh weren't
very much i mean they were appreciated
although that's not the kind of comments
that we were looking for
uh but creative comments i think that we
were able to
uh really really improve on that front
so uh do let us know what you think of
chapter 2
and how are you enjoying the story so
far do let us know
what you think about the uh the other
short stories the tales from kaiser and
well everything you enjoy so far about
this universe
you know things that you would like to
see things that you don't don't enjoy
so basically we just want to get uh
well get any feedback from you to to
start uh
uh basically creating a community around
the the age of kaiser so
hopefully uh hopefully we're on the
right path
uh so yeah uh that's the that's the
video hope you guys
were uh well informed uh and yeah uh
chapter two
chapter three should be arriving maybe
in a you know
maybe in two months time but we'll we'll
see how it goes if not
maybe three but you know with time we
will again we will become faster and
uh and better at uh creating this but uh
it's important that the the general idea
and the you know the the
the main thread of this universe we're
we're creating is um
uh you know is well and then everything
else hopefully will follow
yeah that's it uh click click on it in
the
the first link in the description that
you will see and enjoy it
let us know what you think see you soon